I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello everyone. Hey there. Off-S ladies. Hello, everyone.
我是詹妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起演过《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》并带来只有两个身临其境的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好。嘿，各位。办公室女郎。大家好，各位。
Hey there. Today we're talking about Christening, which is season seven, episode seven, written by Peter Oco and directed by Alex Hardcastle. How about a summary? I thought you'd never ask. It is Cece Helper, it's Christening, and the whole office shows up to the dismay of Jim and Pam.
嘿，各位。今天我们聊的是“洗礼”，也就是第七季第七集，由彼得·奥科编剧，亚历克斯·哈德卡斯尔执导。来个剧情梗概吗？我猜你绝对不会问。那是西西·哈珀特的洗礼，吉姆和帕姆大惊失色的是，整个办公室的人都来了。
Michael is not the Godfather, but during a post-Christening reception with two little food, he is moved by the spirit of the Church parishioners and impulsively joins a youth ministry trip to Mexico. And Andy goes to. I mean, the whole office shows up because Michael invited them. Yes. Not Jim and Pam because Michael invited them. Yes. Not Jim and Pam. Michael invited them. And they didn't know better.
迈克尔不是教父，但在洗礼后只有零星食物的招待会上，他被教会信徒的精神所感动，冲动地加入了去墨西哥的青年宣教之旅。安迪也去了。我是说，整个办公室的人都来了，因为迈克尔邀请了他们。是的。不是吉姆和帕姆，因为迈克尔邀请了他们。是的。不是吉姆和帕姆。迈克尔邀请了他们。而且他们不知情。
Not to come. I know! Like, Archie, like, huh, where did that Jim and Pam didn't invite me? But Michael did, I guess I'll go. I mean, it's really sweet that everyone showed up, actually. It is, but I don't think Jim and Pam invited them. Fast fact number one, both our writer and our director are new on this episode. Yeah.
不该来。我知道！就像，阿奇，等等，怎么回事，吉姆和帕姆没有邀请我？但迈克尔邀请了，我想我会去的。我是说，每个人都出现真的很贴心，其实。是的，但我不认为吉姆和帕姆邀请了他们。第一条幕后趣闻，我们的编剧和导演在这集里都是新人。是的。
Let's start with our director, Alex Hardcastle. He is a British television director and producer. He has directed such shows as New Girl, The Mindy Project, Crazy X Girlfriend, and Grace and Frankie. He was recommended by our executive producer Howard Klein. And I remember him well, he was delightful. He was so charming, you guys, he had a really cute accent. I mean, we were such suckers for the accents Charles McDougall.
让我们从我们的导演亚历克斯·哈德卡斯尔开始。他是一位英国电视导演和制作人。他曾执导过《杰茜驾到》、《明迪烦事多》、《疯狂前女友》和《格蕾丝与弗兰基》等剧集。他是由我们的执行制片人霍华德·克莱因推荐的。我对他印象深刻，他非常讨人喜欢。你们知道吗，他太迷人了，他有一个非常可爱的口音。我是说，我们对查尔斯·麦克杜格尔的口音毫无抵抗力。
I know. Idris. Alex Hardcastle. I know. Randy said he worked with Alex on other productions after the office and he was always awesome. Now let's talk about Peter, a writer. He was a new writer on staff with us for season seven, and he had previously written on Dead Like Me and Pushing Daisies, and Peter was quoted in Andy Green's book about the office, and
我知道。伊德里斯。亚历克斯·哈德卡斯尔。我知道。兰迪说他在《办公室》之后在其他制作中与亚历克斯合作过，他总是那么棒。现在我们来聊聊彼得，一位编剧。他是第七季加入我们团队的新编剧，他以前曾为《死神妙探》和《灵指神探》写过剧本，彼得在安迪·格林的《办公室》一书中被引用，并且
he specifically talked about the christening episode. Oh, what do you say? He said, quote, when I first started, they had this idea for a christening episode, which is as unsexy an episode as you can possibly pitch. And when they brought it up, the entire room looked at me because I had a lot of kids. And that's true. He had five kids. He has a big family. And then he said, I think the thought was, we'll let him write it.
他专门谈到了洗礼那一集。哦，他说什么了？他说，引述如下：“我刚开始的时候，他们对洗礼这一集有个想法，这可能是你能提出的最不性感的剧集了。当他们提出这个想法时，整个房间的人都看着我，因为我有很多孩子。”这倒不假。他有五个孩子。他有一个大家庭。然后他说，我想当时的想法是，让我们让他来写吧。
And I felt this sense of how do you keep what we all loved in Jim and Pam in this post-marriage post-baby world? But he said they just tried to lean into it and acknowledge that the office was as much of a family for Jim and Pam in season seven as it was for Michael. And so that's where they got the idea that in the christening episode, you would bring the office into that story. Yeah. I can imagine your first writing assignment, the christening to be a little tough. I love
我当时有一种感觉，在这个结婚后、有娃后的世界里，你该如何保持我们大家所喜爱的吉姆和帕姆呢？但他说，他们只是试着顺其自然，并承认在第七季中，对于吉姆和帕姆来说，办公室就像对迈克尔一样，也是一个大家庭。所以这就是他们灵感的来源，在洗礼这一集中，你会把办公室带入那个故事中。是的。我能想象你的第一个编剧任务，洗礼，会有点艰难。我喜欢
hearing all of that. My memory of Peter is that he was so nice. And I was a big fan of dead like me. So I was like, oh my gosh, that's such a cool show. And now we get one of the writers from that show. One of the fun parts about working in this industry is that you get to run into people you're fans of and you get to hear all the inside scoop about what went into making this show or movie that you love so much.
听到这一切。我对彼得的记忆是，他太好了。我是《死神妙探》的超级粉丝，所以我想，哦天哪，这是一部太酷的剧了。现在我们得到了该剧的一位编剧。在这个行业工作的好处之一就是，你能遇到你的偶像，还能听到关于制作你如此喜爱的剧集或电影的各种内幕消息。
Mm-hmm. Do you want Fastback too? Can I guess what it is? What is it? Because we're becoming like that old married couple. A little bit in the pot. You know what I order for dinner? Maybe.
嗯。你想要第二条幕后趣闻吗？我能猜到是什么吗？是什么？因为我们变得像那对老夫老妻了。在播客里有点像。你知道我晚餐点什么吗？也许吧。
I'm gonna guess Sam you guess too. Okay. FastFact 2, I'm gonna guess that it's a location breakdown of the church. Uh, history of uh, Chris andnings. Ha ha ha ha. Those are two good guesses, I think. Angela is correct. Is that?
我来猜，萨姆你也猜。好的。幕后趣闻2，我猜这是教堂的取景地解析。呃，克里斯·宁格斯的历史。哈哈哈哈。我想这是两个很好的猜测。安吉拉猜对了。是吗？
Yes. Woo hoo! We had a fan question from Fabie, a new hamster, who wanted to know where were the church scenes filmed. It was beautiful. It was gorgeous. We shot at church of the angels in Pasadena. And I want to give a shout out to the scale Lindsay and her blog quote,
是的。呜呼！我们有一个来自新仓鼠法比的粉丝问题，他想知道教堂的场景是在哪里拍摄的。太美了。太华丽了。我们在帕萨迪纳的天使教堂拍摄的。我想向博主林赛和她的博客致敬，引述如下，
I'm not a stalker because she goes around to different like film and television locations. Okay. And then she writes a little history about them and she pulled together all this cool information on Church of the Angels. What's here at? So this church was built in 1889 and it is the oldest church in Pasadena. It was built by Mrs. Francis E. Campbell Johnston in memory of her husband, Alexander Robert Campbell Johnston, who was one of the first settlers of Pasadena. He was British. And the church's design was based on Homee St. Mary's Church in Surrey. I was going to say it looks like an old sort of English country church.
“我不是跟踪狂，”因为她四处参观不同的电影和电视取景地。好的。然后她写了一点关于它们历史的文章，她把关于天使教堂的所有这些酷炫的信息汇集在起。这是在哪？所以这座教堂建于1889年，是帕萨迪纳最古老的教堂。它是由弗朗西斯·E·坎贝尔·约翰斯顿夫人为纪念她的丈夫亚历山大·罗伯特·坎贝尔·约翰斯顿而建的，亚历山大是帕萨迪纳最早的定居者之一。他是英国人。这座教堂的设计是以萨里的霍姆圣玛丽教堂为基础的。我本来想说它看起来像一座古老的英国乡村教堂。
I thought you were going to say it looks like horn bee st. Mary's. Yeah, definitely. That would have been money or, but it really did when I was looking at it. I was like, oh, all the old stone and all of that. Yeah. Well, speaking of stone, the very first corner stone of the church was laid in place by Francis herself. It's an Episcopalian church, and I don't know if you remember this, but there's a large pipe organ inside the church. It is functional.
我以为你要说它看起来像霍恩比圣玛丽教堂。是的，绝对的。那可太有钱了，或者说当我看着它时确实如此。我就想，哦，所有的老石头以及所有这些。是的。嗯，说到石头，教堂的第一个基石是弗朗西斯本人安放的。这是一座圣公会教堂，我不知道你还记不记得，教堂里面有一个大型管风琴。它是可以使用的。
It was built in 1889 by the Roosevelt organ works in New York City. This church has been featured in a lot of film and television. It has appeared on Nots Landing, which is why Lindsay stalked it. She was a Nots Landing fan. It has also appeared on Desperate Housewives, the X-Files, Buffy the Vampire Slayer, the West Wing, Jag, the Mick Jagger.
它是由纽约市的罗斯福管风琴厂于1889年建造的。这座教堂曾在许多电影和电视中出现过。它曾出现在《解脱》中，这就是为什么林赛跟踪它的原因。她是个《解脱》迷。它还出现在《绝望的主妇》、《X档案》、《吸血鬼猎人巴菲》、《白宫群英》、《执法悍将》、米克·贾格尔的
God gave me everything I want music video. The movies just married Heather's, and of course the office. That church has a longer resume than I do. That's impressive. And incidentally, our base camp with all our trailers was in the Rose Bowl parking lots. Well, I left that location breakdown. Thank you.
《上帝给了我想要的一切》音乐录影带中。电影《新婚告急》、《希瑟姐妹》，当然还有《办公室》。那座教堂的简历比我还长。这令人印象深刻。顺便说一句，我们所有拖车的大本营都在玫瑰碗停车场。好吧，我喜欢那个取景地解析。谢谢。
Thank you, Lindsay, for blogging about it. Couldn't find your last name. Fastback number three is all about our amazing guest star, Zoe Jarman, who played Carla. Carla! Carla! I mean, when she popped up, I immediately started giggling because we were so taken with her when we were shooting. She was so fantastic in her scenes with Steve. She held him toe-to-toe.
谢谢林赛写的博客。找不到你的姓氏。第三条幕后趣闻全关于我们惊艳的客串演员佐伊·贾曼，她饰演卡拉。卡拉！卡拉！我是说，当她出现时，我立刻咯咯笑了起来，因为我们在拍摄时对她太着迷了。她在与史蒂夫的对手戏中表现得太棒了。她与他针锋相对，毫不逊色。
Mm-hmm. Zoe, I was so excited to rewatch these scenes. I could not find Zoe on Instagram or Twitter or anywhere social media. Respect, Zoe. Whenever I can't find somebody, I'm always like, oh, they're a real actor. I do. And so I could not slide into her DMs. Zoe, if you hear this, we would have loved to spoken to you. If you ever do get a social media slide into our DMs. Yes, it's an invitation. Well, let me tell you a little bit about Zoe. She is a comedian sketch performer and also a writer and director. She studied theater at Northwestern University in Chicago and she also studied at both upright Citizens Brigade and
嗯。佐伊，我太兴奋能重温这些场景了。我在Instagram、推特或任何社交媒体上都找不到佐伊。致敬，佐伊。每当我找不到某个人时，我总是想，哦，他们是个真正的演员。我是这么想的。所以我无法私信她。佐伊，如果你听到这个，我们很想和你谈谈。如果你什么时候玩社交媒体，给我们发私信吧。是的，这是一个邀请。好吧，让我向你介绍一下佐伊。她是一位喜剧小品演员，同时也是一位编剧和导演。她在芝加哥西北大学学习戏剧，她还在“直立公民剧团”和
the ground links. I'm sure a lot of people know her as Betsy in the first two seasons of the Mindy project and that was a role that she got thanks to this guest role on the office. I did find an interview with her where she said this. No, quote. I knew Mindy a bit before the show through the comedy community. She's been really supportive and kind to me in the times that I had gotten to be around her. Then she was really nice to me when I was on the set of the office and made me feel really welcome. Zoe said she had a really positive experience doing the office and was really happy with the way her part turned out in the episode. Well, Zoe, we loved you and I kept hoping for some kind of wrap up to Carla's story.
“地面平民剧团”学习过。我相信很多人在《明迪烦事多》的前两季中认识她饰演的贝西，这个角色是她通过客串《办公室》而获得的。我确实找到了对她的一次采访，她在其中说了这样的话。不，引述如下。我在节目播出前通过喜剧社区对明迪略有了解。在我有机会和她在一起的那段时间里，她一直非常支持我，对我也很好。后来我在《办公室》片场时，她对我也非常好，让我感到宾至如归。佐伊说她在《办公室》的经历非常积极，对她在剧中的戏份呈现非常满意。好吧，佐伊，我们爱你，我一直期待卡拉的故事能有个某种结局。
Like, I wanted to hear how it went. I mean, I would have loved if like in season eight. Yes. Someone got a card from her from Carla. Yeah. In Mexico. Mm-hmm. Well, that's all I got for fast facts. Well, I have a fan catch. I'd love to hear it. This starts the beginning of a new DVD. You know, I'm watching the DVDs. New DVD.
比如，我很想听听后来怎么样了。我是说，如果像在第八季里。是的。有人收到来自卡拉的明信片。是的。在墨西哥。嗯。好吧，幕后趣闻就这些了。好吧，我有一个粉丝抓包。我很想听听。这标志着一张新DVD的开始。你知道的，我在看DVD。新DVD。
It's very exciting. Clearly, it's more exciting for me. Jenna's looking at me with such a blank expression. I get very excited, Jenna, when I finish a DVD and I set it aside and I go get the next one. I know you have commented on the DVDs before. Okay, clearly I've brought it up too much, but I have a fan catch from Sam S from Canada. Sam says in the delivery Jim announced that their daughter's name is Cecilia. CC for short. I have the DVD box set, and on the description for the christening episode, it says that her name is Celeste.
太令人兴奋了。显然，对我来说更兴奋。詹妮弗用如此空白的表情看着我。詹妮弗，当我看完一张DVD把它放到一边去拿下一张时，我会非常兴奋。我知道你以前评论过DVD。好吧，显然我提得太多了，但我有一个来自加拿大的萨姆·S的粉丝抓包。萨姆说在《分娩》中，吉姆宣布他们女儿的名字叫塞西莉亚。简称CC。我有DVD套装，在洗礼那一集的介绍上，上面说她的名字叫塞莱斯特。
Quote, it's overcrowded at Jim and Pam's christening for baby Celeste when everyone from the office shows up. But then throughout the rest of the show, she's referred to as Cecilia or CC. Was this a production error? Oh, it had to have been! What did your DVD say, Angela? My DVD said the same!
引述如下，“当办公室的每个人都出现时，吉姆和帕姆为宝宝塞莱斯特举行的洗礼挤满了人。”但在接下来的剧集中，她被称为塞西莉亚或CC。这是一个制作失误吗？哦，一定是！你的DVD上怎么说，安吉拉？我的DVD上说的也是这个！
Celeste! What?! Does anyone else's DVDs say Celeste? Is happening! I think there was a little bit of an oops. There was an oopsie. Sam, I want you to know that you have made Angela's day. Yes, you have, Sam.
塞莱斯特！什么？！还有谁的DVD上说的是塞莱斯特？发生了！我想这是一个小小的失误。出了个小差错。萨姆，我想让你知道你让安吉拉度过了美好的一天。是的，你做到了，萨姆。
You have also scrutinized your DVDs, and that makes Angela's heart happy. It really does. And for anyone else like out of DVD box set that says Celeste, let us know. I think Sam and I need to know. Mm-hmm. Speaking of BabyCC,
你也仔细审查了你的DVD，这让安吉拉的心情很愉快。确实如此。对于任何拥有说她是塞莱斯特的DVD套装的人，请让我们知道。我想萨姆和我都得知道。嗯。说到宝宝CC，
guess what I have, thanks to Joya Balfour from NBC.com. Lady, I hope you're gonna tell me that you have Pam's Christening blog because I couldn't find it, but I remember it existed. Yes, I have it. Joya sent it to me. Here's how it read. CCC's Christening, posted by Pam Halpert on November 4, 2010, at 1942 hours. 1942 hours. Okay, yeah. You know, you minus 12. So I posted it. 7 42 PM didn't say. Well, that's what the 17 is. Oh, right. That's why we're doing military time. Yeah.
你猜我有什么，多亏了NBC.com的乔亚·巴尔福。美女，我希望你要告诉我你拥有帕姆的洗礼博客，因为我找不到，但我记得它存在。是的，我有。乔亚发给我的。它是这样写的。CC的洗礼，由帕姆·哈珀特于2010年11月4日19点42分发布。19点42分。好吧，是的。你知道的，减去12。所以我发布了。晚上7点42分没说。嗯，这就是17的意思。哦，对了。这就是为什么我们用24小时制。是的。
Right. So you don't have to worry if it's AMRPM. Right. When you're in a stressful situation. In the number. Yes. Yes. That way, if things are going down, you know it's nighttime and not the morning.
对的。所以你不必担心是AM还是PM。对的。当你在一个压力山大的情况下时。在数字里。是的。是的。那样的话，如果事情不妙，你知道那是晚上而不是早上。
Yeah. Okay. Here's what it said. Okay. 742 PM. It's official. CC is a member of the Covenant community. The baptism ceremony was beautiful, mostly.
是的。好吧。它是这样说的。好的。晚上7点42分。这是官方消息。CC是圣约社群的成员。洗礼仪式非常美丽，大部分是这样。
CC looked so cute in her christening gown, she was almost in it long enough to get a picture. It was wonderful to see all of our friends and family at the church. My apologies to everyone that went to the reception. We promised that CC's wedding will be catered. Although the day didn't go as smoothly as planned, all in all, it was a truly blessed event. I know all babies are equal in the eyes of the Lord, but Cece was definitely the cutest baby there.
CC穿着她的洗礼长袍看起来太可爱了，她穿它的时间差不多够拍张照片了。很高兴在教堂看到我们所有的朋友和家人。向所有去参加招待会的人道歉。我们保证CC的婚礼会备有餐饮服务。尽管这一天并没有像计划的那样顺利，但总的来说，这是一场真正蒙福的活动。我知道在上帝眼中所有的婴儿都是平等的，但CC绝对是那里最可爱的宝宝。
Aw! Very sweet. Pam's baby blog. Who is she writing this for? It's like who I used to write my journals for. Yeah, I don't know who's reading her blog I might have brought a journal today Please say yes. Yes. I found one of my journal
啊！非常甜蜜。帕姆的宝宝博客。她这是为谁写的？这就像我以前为谁写日记一样。是的，我不知道谁在读她的博客我今天可能带了一本日志请说有。是的。我找到了我的一本日志
All right, we're gonna take a break. Uh-huh We're gonna come back and break down this episode and at some point Angela will be getting out her journal. Oh I can see it. I just want to knock it. Wait, I just need Jenna to read. I just need Jenna to read what's on the front of my journal. I am here to live out loud. Yeah, yes I am guys. Yes I am. And when we come back, we're going to break down the christening. Get into my journal and who knows what else. I have a present for you. You do? Oh my gosh.
好吧，我们要休息一下。嗯哼我们将回来剖析这一集，在某个时刻安吉拉会掏出她的日记。哦，我能看到它。我只是不想打扰它。等等，我只需要詹妮弗读。我只需要詹妮弗读我日记封面上写的东西。我是来大声活出自我的。是的，是的，我，伙计们。是的，我是。当我们回来时，我们将剖析洗礼。进入我的日记，还有谁知道什么别的。我有一件礼物给你。你有的？哦，天哪。
There's so much to do today. We'll be right back. This episode starts with Pam. In her role as office administrator administrator and she is leading a conference remeading all about hygiene. Yeah, and she's got a big sign. If you go to 12 seconds, it says, Saber hygiene day. Simicolin.
今天有太多事要做。我们马上回来。这一集从帕姆开始。在她担任办公室管理员的角色中，她正在领导一个关于卫生的会议。是的，她有一个大牌子。如果你去到12秒，上面写着，萨博卫生日。西米科林。
Simple steps to a cleaner working environment. Always wash your hands. Remember to get your flu shot. Wipe down your desk daily. Stay home when you are sick or contagious, use the hand sanitizing station often. Dwight isn't happy about the hand sanitizing stations or any of these suggestions, really. He says that the best way to not get sick is to be exposed to germs and he would like a hand-de-sanitizing station.
打造更清洁工作环境的简单步骤。总是洗手。记得去打流感疫苗。每天擦拭你的办公桌。生病或具有传染性时待在家里，经常使用洗手液消毒站。德怀特对洗手消毒站或任何这些建议都不满意，真的。他说不生病的最好方法是接触病菌，他想要一个反洗手消毒站。
Did you hear what he wants in his hand-de-sanitizing station. Did you hear what he wants in his hand desanetizing station? No, I missed it. He wants, and I quote, a simple bowl at every juncture filled with dirt, vomit, fecal matter. Oh God. And then he gets cut off. What? What the heck? This got me curious because Pam said, according to a study done by the University of Arizona, they discovered that your keyboards have hundreds of times more bacteria per square inch than a toilet seat. That's true. It is true. I know.
你听到他在他的反洗手消毒站里想要什么了吗。你听到他在他的反洗手消毒站里想要什么了吗？没有，我漏掉了。他想要，引述如下，在每个交界处都有一个装满泥土、呕吐物、粪便的简单的碗。哦天哪。然后他被打断了。什么？搞什么鬼？这让我很好奇，因为帕姆说，根据亚利桑那大学的一项研究，他们发现你的键盘每平方英寸的细菌比马桶座圈多数百倍。那是真的。确实如此。我知道。
So does your phone, by the way. Oh, I went to WebMD. Are you ready for the top five most germy places in an office? Yeah. Number one, elevator buttons. Many of them don't work as we've learned. Yeah, stop touching them. Who cares? Number two, door handles. Mm-hmm. Number three, your actual desk, like your actual desk top. Okay. Number four, your keyboard. Number five, your telephone. Mm-hmm. Yeah.
顺便说一句，你的手机也是。哦，我上了WebMD。你准备好了解办公室里细菌最多的五个地方了吗？yeah。第一，电梯按钮。正如我们所知，其中许多都不起作用。是的，别再碰它们了。谁在乎呢？第二，门把手。嗯哼。第三，你实际的办公桌，就像你实际的桌面一样。好的。第四，你的键盘。第五，你的电话。嗯哼。是的。
Is this a good time to tell you that when I go into like a hotel room or something, I wipe down the remote and the light switches and like everything with a little antibacterial wipe because I watched a whole, you know, whatever date line or something like that. I saw the date line all about it. I feel like we all saw that date line where they went in with that special light and everything glowed blue because it was poop or earwax or something disgusting. The most disturbing part of that show for me was when they showed like secret cameras of how they don't really clean the water glasses that are left in the bathroom.
现在是告诉你的好时机吗，当我走进酒店房间或类似地方时，我会用一块小抗菌湿巾擦拭遥控器、电灯开关和所有东西，因为我看过一个完整的，你知道的，什么日德兰或类似的东西。我看了关于它的日德兰。我觉得我们都看过那个日德兰，他们带着那盏特殊的灯进去，每样东西都闪着蓝光，因为那是便便或耳屎或诸如此类恶心的东西。那个节目中最令人不安的部分是他们展示了秘密摄像头，展示了他们是如何不真正清洗留在浴室里的水杯的。
Like a lot of places they just like sort of rinsed them under water using the same rag that they had just used to like clean the bathroom. I never use those cups. Okay. I don't. Well, I've been using them, but I might not anymore. I put my makeup brushes in them. I don't drink out of them.
就像很多地方他们只是用水冲洗一下，用他们刚才用来清理浴室的同一块抹布。我从不使用那些杯子。好吧。我不用。好吧，我一直在用，但我可能不再用了。我把我的化妆刷放在里面。我不从里面喝水。
That's a no for me. Okay, well, just saying.. That's a no for me. Okay. Well, just saying. It's a new no for me. Well, Pam also suggests that you should cough into your elbow as a great way to prevent the spreading of germs or sneeze into your elbow, like the Dracula. Yeah, the vampire cough. Mm-hmm.
这对我不行。好吧，只是说说。。这对我不行。好吧，只是说说。对我来说是一个新的“不行”。好吧，帕姆还建议你应该把咳嗽打在你的手肘里，这是防止病菌传播的好方法，或者把喷嚏打在手肘里，就像德古拉那样。是的，吸血鬼咳嗽。嗯哼。
And I read some studies on that, and that is good advice. Yeah, they should do that. They teach all of our kids to do that at school. Mm-hmm. And now all my kids cough like that. Well, Dwight says that he would rather people just cough or sneeze directly on him. So we have a montage of people sneezing on him, his food, all kinds of things. We got a fan question from Rosie S and Ed and
我读了一些关于这方面的研究，这是个好建议。是的，他们应该那样做。他们在学校教我们所有的孩子那样做。嗯哼。现在我的所有孩子都那样咳嗽。好吧，德怀特说他宁愿人们直接把咳嗽或喷嚏打在他身上。所以我们有了一段人们把喷嚏打在他身上、他的食物上以及各种东西上的蒙太奇。我们有一个来自苏格兰伯罗的罗西·S和埃德的粉丝问题
Burrow Scotland who said, I spotted a small error in the cold open. What Rosie? Dwight talks about the cost of wool in Transylvania. And he blames it on the euro. But Rosie points out that Transylvania is in Romania, which does not use the euro. It's in Europe, but they have their own currency. To white. And they have for a while. Now, I believe they are converting to the Euro in a few years, however. Do I got it wrong? That's rare.
，他们说，我在冷场中发现了一个小错误。什么罗西？德怀特谈到了特兰西瓦尼亚羊毛的成本。他把这归咎于欧元。但罗西指出特兰西瓦尼亚在罗马尼亚，那里不使用欧元。它在欧洲，但他们有自己的货币。德怀特。他们已经这样有一段时间了。不过，我相信他们将在几年后改用欧元。德怀特弄错了？这很罕见。
That's rare. Dwight, often we find, has got it right, but not this time. The episode starts outside of the church. Angela is walking up to Jim and Pam and they're holding little Sexy. Yeah, the whole office is kind of congregated outside before the ceremony begins. And I'll have you know, Angela, we shot this episode, the week of September 13, 2010. And we are recording this podcast almost exactly 12 years later in September 2022. That is crazy. Now, you know what the temperature is today, right? Oh yeah, it's like 103. Yes. We did all of these exterior scenes outside this church in heavy wool coats, pretending it was fall because this aired in November. Yeah. But luckily it was only 83 degrees. But still, when you watch all of these scenes outside the church, just know that we are
这很罕见。我们经常发现德怀特是对的，但这次不是。这一集从教堂外面开始。安吉拉走向吉姆和帕姆，他们抱着小性感。是的，整个办公室的人在仪式开始前都聚集在外面。我得告诉你，安吉拉，我们拍摄这一集的周是2010年9月13日的那周。我们录制这个播客几乎正好是12年后的2022年9月。太疯狂了。现在，你知道今天的温度是多少，对吧？哦，是的，大约103华氏度。是的。我们在厚重的羊毛大衣里在这座教堂外面拍摄了所有这些外景，假装是秋天，因为这集是在11月播出的。是的。但幸运的是只有83度。不过，当你观看教堂外面的所有这些场景时，只要知道我们
very hot. We did not put a coat on baby CC on purpose. We did not want to overheat the baby. But Pam is in a wool coat. Well, I got so tickled rewatching these scenes, Jenna, because I had so much fun being so sweet to the baby and so snarky to Jim and Pam. I know. I really loved those turns every time. I even went to the shooting draft Jenna to see if there was stage direction about it.
非常热。我们没有故意给宝宝CC穿外套。我们不想让宝宝过热。但帕姆穿着一件羊毛大衣。好吧，重温这些场景让我感到非常开心，詹妮弗，因为对宝宝那么温柔、对吉姆和帕姆那么刻薄，我得到了很多乐趣。我知道。我真的很喜欢每一次的那些转折。我甚至去看了拍摄剧本，詹妮弗，看看有没有关于它的舞台方向。
Mm-hmm. And it said, Angela is cold to Jim and Pam and cute see to see see. Hmm. And you know, Jenna, in this episode, I have two improv lines that made it in. Oh, I think I know one of them. Well, the first one comes in this little couple of dialogue when Angela turns to Jim and Pam, and she goes, Jim, Pam, and the pressure to Spundle of God's gift to everything, and then she goes back to Jim and Pam. I wish you both a pleasant day.
嗯。上面写着，安吉拉对吉姆和帕姆很冷淡，对CC很可爱。嗯哼，你知道的，詹妮弗，在这集中，我有两句即兴台词被用了进去。哦，我想我知道其中一句。好吧，第一句出现在这几句对话中，当安吉拉转向吉姆和帕姆时，她说：“吉姆，帕姆，以及万物神圣礼物的压力宝贝，”然后她又转向吉姆和帕姆。“祝你们俩度过愉快的一天。”
And then I am provised. And you too, yes, praise God. Okay. Aw. I just couldn't get enough of those little girls. Those babies were so cute. People just turned into jelly around those babies. I know.
然后我即兴发挥：“还有你，是的，赞美上帝。”好的。啊。我对那些小女孩爱不释手。那些宝宝太可爱了。人们在那些宝宝周围简直变成了果冻。我知道。
They were the sweetest. Once again, they were played by Bailey and Sienna. Although there were a few times that we used the creepy jelly baby. Oh, I caught it. Yeah. Phil got it for us. They're really expensive. We've talked about these before.
她们是最甜美的。再次强调，她们是由贝利和西耶那饰演的。虽然有几次我们使用了那个诡异的果冻宝宝。哦，我抓到了。是的。菲尔给我们弄来的。它们真的很贵。我们以前讨论过这些。
They're like thousands of dollars. And we had to be careful with them. I have some catches. I have some jelly baby catches. I do too. But in these opening scenes, it was all Bailey and Sienna. You know, in the shooting draft, there's a series of talking heads
它们要几千美元。我们必须小心对待它们。我有一些抓包。我有一些果冻宝宝抓包。我也有。但在这些开场场景中，全是贝利和西耶那。你知道的，在拍摄剧本中，有一系列谈话头
where everyone would have weighed in on whether or not they want kids. Oh, yeah. But Andy saying that he wanted nard pups is the one that made it in and it's definitely the best one. Well as everyone's entering the church, Dwight is going to hand out his business cards. And you know what cracked me up about this moment Jenna, it's very small, but Rain chose to deliver the line where he hands the business cards in the way that when you walk into church they hand you the program.
，每个人都会对他们是否想要孩子发表看法。哦，是的。但安迪说他想要纳德小狗的那句话被采用了，这绝对是最好的一句。好吧，当每个人都进入教堂时，德怀特去散发他的名片。你知道这个时刻什么让我捧腹大笑吗，詹妮弗，非常小，但雷恩选择用那种你走进教堂时他们递给你节目单的方式来交付散发名片的那句台词。
Yes. I thought that was so great. He was like, Dwight Shrute, regional sales, Dwight Shrute, business card. Like he did that cadence. Yes. This was part of a bigger storyline for Dwight. It's in deleted scenes. It comes out throughout the episode where he is really trying to work this church crowd for business.
是的。我觉得太棒了。他就像是，“德怀特·舒鲁特，区域销售，德怀特·舒鲁特，名片。”就像他那样有节奏感。是的。这是德怀特更大故事线的一部分。它在被删减片段中。在整集中都有体现，他真的很想在这个教堂里拉拢人做生意。
Well, the one person who's having trouble getting into the church is Toby. He says it's been a few years since he's attended a church service. Yeah. He and the big guy have some catching up to do. I went to deleted scenes and looked in our candy bag alts because I was curious
好吧，唯一一个进教堂遇到麻烦的人是托比。他说他已经好几年没去教堂做礼拜了。是的。他和那个大人物有些话要叙旧。我去了被删减片段，在我们的糖果袋备选里找，因为我很好奇
if there was any more backstory. I mean, we learned in season five, casual Friday, that Toby had been in seminary and dropped out because he wanted to have sex with his girlfriend Kathy. Yes. And then followed her to Scranton and took the first job he could find, which was in human resources at Dundermifflin.
是否还有更多的背景故事。我的意思是，我们在第五季的“随性星期五”中了解到，托比曾在神学院学习过，但因为想和女友凯茜发生性关系而退学了。是的。然后跟着她去了斯克兰顿，找到了他能找到的第一份工作，那就是在邓德米弗林的人力资源部。
Well, I'm curious what you found because we had fan questions from Rachel C. and Suffolk Virginia and Kaylee E. and Indianapolis, Indiana, who said, so Toby has trouble going into the church, but wasn't he at Jim and Pam's wedding as well as Phyllis's wedding? He didn't have a problem going into those churches. Oh, that's such a good catch.
好吧，我很好奇你发现了什么，因为我们收到了来自弗吉尼亚州萨福克的雷切尔·C和印第安纳州印第安纳波利斯的凯莉·E的粉丝问题，他们说，所以托比进教堂有困难，但他难道不是也出席了吉姆和帕姆的婚礼以及菲利斯的婚礼吗？他进那些教堂可没什么困难。哦，这真是个好抓包。
Well the candy bag alts were all versions of this. Here's one of them. Toby, I studied for the ministry, but well, it didn't work out. So I'm going to walk into the church, maybe look up at the altar and say, hey, remember me, it's Toby. Okay. They were all versions of that that he left the church, and there was some mystery, and he's got a little bit of beef, maybe with the big man. You know where my brain went. What you know who wouldn't want to enter a church because they have a problem with God who a Strangler oh And he started strangling after Jim and Pam's wedding and Phyllis's wedding. Yep
好吧，糖果袋备选都是这类的版本。这是其中一个。“托比，我曾为主的事工学习过，但嗯，没成功。所以我要走进教堂，也许抬头看着圣坛说，嘿，还记得我吗，我是托比。”好的。这些都是他离开教堂的各种版本，有些神秘，他可能对那个大人物有点意见。你知道我的大脑去哪了吗。什么，你知道谁不想进教堂因为他们对上帝有意见，一个勒索犯哦，而且他在吉姆和帕姆的婚礼以及菲利斯的婚礼之后开始勒索了。是的
Sam Sam is Toby the Scranton Strangler. Will the reddit threads be a buzz with this new development? Michael of course is gonna try to weasel his way into the family sitting area at the church. I mean this is what he does. Remember Phyllis is wedding. He wanted to be in the family photo. Mm-hmm. And he's doing his godfather impression. And I loved this line so much, Jenna. You said, you know, I love it when you do that voice, but today I'm sorry. I need you to tell me that you know you're not CC's Godfather. And then Michael's like, yeah.
萨姆，萨姆，托比是斯克兰顿勒索犯吗？Reddit的帖子会因为这个新发展而炸开锅吗？迈克尔当然会试图混进教堂的家属座位区。我的意思是，这就是他会做的事。还记得菲利斯的婚礼吗。他想拍全家福。嗯哼。他在模仿他的教父。我太喜欢这句台词了，詹妮弗。你说，“你知道的，我喜欢你学那个声音，但今天我很抱歉。我需要你告诉我，你知道你不是CC的教父。”然后迈克尔就像是，是的。
And Pam says, I'm sorry, Michael. I need you to say it. I'm so sorry. I have to say that exchange sort of reminded me a little bit of Carol stills. Yes, I felt like it was something Carol would say to Michael. Michael, we're breaking up. I need you to know that.
帕姆说，“我很抱歉，迈克尔。我需要你说出来。”“我很抱歉。我不得不说那段交流让我想起了卡洛尔·斯蒂尔斯。”是的，我觉得那是卡洛尔会对迈克尔说的话。迈克尔，我们要分手了。我需要你知道这一点。
And I need you to say it back to me. Exactly. Well, I don't know if you noticed, but little Cece is holding a little toy in her hand through all these scenes. I did. It's like a little tiger. So that was a real little toy. I don't know if it was Bailey or Santa in the scene,
我需要你对我说回来。没错。好吧，我不知道你有没有注意到，小CC在所有这些场景中手里都拿着一个小玩具。我注意到了。就像一只小老虎。所以那是一个真正的玩具。我不知道那是贝利还是圣地亚哥在那个场景中，
but it was just a great way to help make her feel secure. That was something that we did sometime. We just let them carry their own blankies or their own little toys. Yeah. You know, something that is revealed in the scene, Angela, is that the godfather of Jim and Pam's baby is their friend Seth, whose wife Pam met at mommy and me. I mean, baby is their friend Seth, whose wife Pam met at mommy and me. I mean, isn't that sort of just like a quick turnaround to Godfather status? Fan mail flurry, Angela! So many people wrote in to say, why did Pam and Jim choose two people they essentially just met?
但这绝对是帮助她感到安全的好方法。那是我们有时会做的事情。我们只是让他们带着自己的小毯子或他们自己的小玩具。嗯哼。你知道的，在这个场景中透露的一件事，安吉拉，是吉姆和帕姆孩子的教父是他们的朋友塞思，帕姆是在妈妈和宝宝聚会上认识他的妻子的。我的意思是，孩子是他们的朋友塞思，帕姆是在妈妈和宝宝聚会上认识他的妻子的。我的意思是，这难道不就像是光速转变成教父地位吗？粉丝邮件风暴，安吉拉！那么多人写信来问，为什么帕姆和吉姆要选择两个他们基本上刚认识的人
To meet these Godparents rather than one of their siblings are even an old friend. I am part of the fan mail flurry. Well, this made me wonder, hey, where is Pam's sister? Yeah, this is a big moment for Pam. I know. Also, where is her friend Isabel? Yeah.
来当这些教父母，而不是他们的兄弟姐妹甚至是老朋友呢？我是粉丝邮件风暴的一部分。好吧，这让我想知道，嘿，帕姆的妹妹在哪？是的，这对帕姆来说是个大时刻。我知道。还有，她的朋友伊莎贝尔在哪？是的。
I mean, a lot of people are no shows. Jim's brothers. Yeah. They all live in town. Jim's brothers. Yeah. They all live in town. It's not like these people had to travel far. I don't know. Mm. Maybe you know, we did have a lot of guest stars
我是说，很多人都没有出现。吉姆的兄弟们。是的。他们都住在镇上。吉姆的兄弟们。是的。他们都住在镇上。这些人又不用长途跋涉。我不知道。嗯。也许你知道，我们确实有很多客串演员
in this episode. Maybe we just like couldn't pack anybody else in. Well, I'm with Michael. Michael's like, he can't believe that these two in his eyes, random people are are going to hold such a huge part in C.C.'s life. We never find out the godmother's name. It's just Seth and his wife. Anyway, well, the pastor is going to welcome everyone. I loved this scene. It just reminded me so much of Sundays during football season in church because the pastor says what a terrific day this is,
在这一集里。也许我们只是塞不下其他人了。好吧，我和迈克尔感同身受。迈克尔觉得，他不敢相信这两个在他眼里看来是随便的人，将在CC的生活中占据如此重要的部分。我们永远不知道教母的名字。只有塞思和他的妻子。无论如何，牧师要欢迎大家。我太喜欢这个场景了。它让我想起了足球赛季周日去教堂的情景，因为牧师说这是多么棒的一天，
and not just because the Eagles are playing, and Kevin is so tickled. This is like the biggest laugh that he's had in a while. We had a fan question from Kirsten L. in Minnesota. I really appreciate that the church pastor was cast as female. As someone who is considering becoming a Lutheran pastor myself, there aren't many women pastors depicted in the media.
不仅因为老鹰队在比赛，凯文高兴坏了。这是他一段时间以来笑得最大的一次。我们收到了来自明尼苏达州的克尔斯滕·L的粉丝问题。我真的很感激教堂牧师由女性扮演。作为一个正在考虑自己成为一名路德会牧师的人，媒体上描绘的女性牧师并不多。
I'm wondering how this came about. Was Alison Jones looking for a woman specifically for this role? Is this woman an actual pastor? Well, Kirsten, the script called for a woman to play this role. Minister Gail was played by an actress named Carolyn Wilson. She's also appeared in Veepe and Space Force.
我想知道这是怎么实现的。艾莉森·琼斯是专门为这个角色寻找女性吗？这位女性是真正的牧师吗？好吧，克尔斯滕，剧本确实要求由女性来扮演这个角色。盖尔牧师由一位名叫卡罗琳·威尔逊的女演员扮演。她还出演过《副总统》和《太空部队》。
And get this! She was the casting associate for that 70s show, including the episode in which I played Stacey Wanamaker. Huh! Yeah. Huh, yeah. Well, I thought Carolyn did a great job. So believable. I mean, I would have believed she was a real pastor and I was like, I wanna hear her sermon.
听着这个！她还是《那70年代秀》的选角助理，包括我扮演斯黛西·沃纳梅克的那一集。哼！是的。哼，是的。好吧，我觉得卡罗琳做得很好。太逼真了。我是说，我会相信她是一个真正的牧师，我当时就想，我想听她的布道。
Well, as part of her welcoming everyone to church that day, the pastor is also gonna share with us that their young adult ministry is gonna be leaving for Mexico. And they all like applaud. They're very excited. And they're also going to have their prayers and remembrance section. Yes, Justin's mom, who was played by Sarah Zincir, is just going to ask everyone to keep
好吧，作为她那天欢迎大家去教堂的一部分，牧师还将与我们分享他们的青年成人事工将前往墨西哥。他们都鼓掌。他们非常兴奋。他们还将有祷告和缅怀环节。是的，由莎拉·津齐尔饰演的贾斯汀的妈妈，将要求每个人把
Justin and their thoughts and in their prayers. And then there is going to be a standoff for who speaks next, because both Dwight and a gentleman stand up at the same time and Dwight stares the man down until he sits, which was an amazing moment in my opinion. Well, Dwight is now gonna just basically hit everyone up to buy a printer. It's like so inappropriate.
贾斯汀放在他们的思念和祷告中。然后将会有一个对峙，看谁先发言，因为德怀特和一个男士同时站了起来，德怀特一直盯着那个男士直到他坐下，依我看，这是一个惊人的时刻。好吧，德怀特现在基本上要向每个人推销打印机了。这太不合适了。
And I have a jelly baby catch. Oh, is it at five minutes and 55 seconds? Yeah. Yes, during this whole scene, I had Jelly Baby, and I hope you noted some of the ways that I was trying to move Jelly Baby to make it look like it was a real baby. You were like bobbing her on your knee. Yeah. And like kind of like moving her arm with my thumb. Mm-hmm.
我有一个果冻宝宝抓包。哦，是在五分五十五秒吗？是的，在整个场景中，我都拿着果冻宝宝，我希望你注意到了我试图移动果冻宝宝以使其看起来像个真正的宝宝的一些方式。你就像是在膝盖上颠着她。是的。然后有点像用大拇指移动她的胳膊。嗯哼。
Lady, this reminded me of the most famous jelly baby in a movie. Do you remember it? Oh, I do, I do, I do. Wait, no, I've got it, because Josh and I were like, this is ridiculous, this is a big budget movie. Wait, wait, wait, no, I have it. Wait, I can see the guy's face. Bradley Cooper.
美女，这让我想起了电影中最著名的果冻宝宝。你还记得吗？哦，我记得，我记得，我记得。等等，不，我想起来了，因为乔什和我当时觉得，这太荒谬了，这是一部大预算电影。等等，等等，不，我想起来了。我能看到那个家伙的脸。布莱德利·库珀。
Yes, Bradley Cooper. In American Sniper. Yes, he's holding this baby that is so thick. He does a lot of the same kind of jelly baby stuff I was doing like there's one part. I rewatched it where you see him take his thumb and move the baby's arm, but this is like an emotional scene.
是的，布莱德利·库珀。在《美国狙击手》中。是的，他抱着这个那么厚的婴儿。他做了很多和我做的差不多的果冻宝宝动作，比如有一部分。我重温了一下，你看到他用大姆指去移动婴儿的胳膊，但这却是一个情感戏。
Yeah, and that baby was so distracting. And I feel like he was doing a really good performance, but all I could look at was this jelly baby. This is like an emotional scene. Yeah. And that baby was so distracting. And I feel like he was doing a really good performance. But all I could look at was this jelly baby. When this came out and it was all over the news, I found an audio clip. There's plenty of buzz and controversy surrounding American sniper moving tours in Cone Boy.
是的，那个婴儿太让人分心了。我觉得他的表演真的很棒，但我能看到的只有这个果冻宝宝。这却是一个情感戏。是的，那个婴儿太让人分心了。我觉得他的表演真的很棒，但我能看到的只有这个果冻宝宝。当这个出来并且闹得满城风雨时，我找到了一个音频剪辑。围绕着《美国狙击手》移动的卡恩男孩，有很多议论和争议。
But this morning moviegoers are highlighting one layering issue in particular. Ah! Do you see it? The baby. It's a fake. It's a prop doll. For one minute and thirteen seconds Bradley Cooper pats cuddles cradles and also gently lays down that fake baby.
但今天早上，电影观众正在强调一个特别的层叠问题。啊！你看到了吗？那个婴儿。那是假的。是一个道具娃娃。在一分钟十三秒里，布莱德利·库珀拍拍、拥抱、怀抱，并且还轻轻放下那个假婴儿。
Now Twitter erupting with the hashtag fakebabywithpostlike. Did they not trust Bradley Cooper with a real baby? And had CPR class the other morning, found the baby used an American sniper. So I can't remember who it is, but someone associated with the movie tweeted, but then deleted why they used the fake baby? What was the tweet? It said something like the real baby showed up with a fever, and then the second baby didn't show up, And so they had to just use fake baby and do their best. Why do you have to delete that tweet?
现在推特上爆发了话题标签“假婴儿”，配文如：“他们难道不敢把真婴儿交给布莱德利·库珀吗？”“那天早上上了急救课，找到了《美国狙击手》里用的那个婴儿。”所以我不记得是谁了，但某个与电影相关的人发了推特，但随后删除了他们为什么使用假婴儿的原因？那条推特是什么？它大概是说真实的婴儿发烧出现，然后第二个婴儿没有出现，所以他们只能用假婴儿并尽力而为。你为什么要删除那条推特？
That's just information. I don't know, I guess. Maybe it was like not his place to say. I don't know. Why there was a fake baby? I don't know. Or maybe the studio was like, don't call out the fake baby. Yeah, exactly.
那只是信息。我不知道，我猜。也许那不是他该说的话。我不知道。为什么会有假婴儿？我不知道。或者也许制片厂说，别指出那是假婴儿。是的，没错。
Enough with the fake baby. I loved that clip from the news so much because I loved how many different stings were in their sand. Did you hear them? There was like the screech and the glass breaking. And like, I don't know, was there a helicopter? It was like, it was like,
够了，假婴儿。我太喜欢新闻里的那个片段了，因为我喜欢他们沙子里的各种刺。你听到它们了吗？就像有尖叫声和玻璃破碎声。而且，我不知道，有直升机吗？就像是，就像是，
a two-time radio recording. Yeah, there were so many things. Well, I have a great photo of our jelly baby. It was in between scenes. It was pretty hot because they kept turning off the air when we would film. I was in the main part of the church sitting area. You were up on the dais and I looked over at you and you looked at me and the jelly baby had flopped over kind of falling off your lap. And I took your picture. It's in our book, the Office BFFs. It cracks me up every time I see it. I love that we have that picture because Jelly Baby was a big part of my life,
一个两台收音机的录音。是的，有太多东西了。好吧，我有一张我们果冻宝宝的伟大照片。那是在场景之间。挺热的，因为我们拍摄时他们一直关掉空调。我在教堂座位区的正中间。你在高台上，我看着你，你看着我，果冻宝宝已经倒下了，有点从你膝盖上掉下来了。我给你拍了张照片。它在我们的书《办公室闺蜜》里。每次看到它我都捧腹大笑。我很高兴我们有那张照片，因为果冻宝宝是我生活中的重要部分，
starting now till the end of the show. Yeah, you spent a lot of time with Jelly Baby. And then you did too. And then I did too. And Jelly babies are heavy. And if you're hot, they can also make you more hot. Oh, we got another fan question from Angela V. An Ontario Canada who asked, who picked the hymns for this episode? Also, Jim Devar Singhs, he's laughing with Pam. Oh, okay, good catch. Randy said most of the hymns were chosen
从现在一直到剧集结束。是的，你花了很多时间陪果冻宝宝。然后你也一样。然后我也一样。果冻宝宝很重。如果你觉得热，它们也会让你更热。哦，我们收到了来自安大略省安吉拉·V的另一个粉丝问题，她问，谁为这一集挑选了赞美诗？还有，吉姆在对口型唱歌，他在和帕姆笑。哦，好的，好抓包。兰迪说大多数赞美诗都是挑选的
because they were public domain with the exception of one, which was, with grateful hearts, our faith professing, that was scripted and it cost $5,000 to license about the cost of a jelly baby. Well, I think it's time for a break, and we have a few things outstanding. Mm-hmm, we have a journal. Yep, we have a gift.
因为它们是公共版权，只有一个除外，那就是《怀着感恩的心，我们信仰表白》，那是剧本写好的，花了我5000美元购买版权，大约是一个果冻宝宝的成本。好吧，我想是时候休息一下了，我们还有几件事没解决。嗯哼，我们有一份日记。是的，我们有一件礼物。
Yes, baby Cece needs a whole new outfit. Yep, let's take a break and get to it. And someone stole the scones. I won't say who. What? I didn't steal them! Someone else put them in my bag. Mm-hmm.
是的，宝宝CC需要一套全新的衣服。是的，我们休息一下去解决它。有人偷了司康饼。我不会说是谁。什么？我没有偷！是别人把它放进我包里的。嗯哼。
All right. We are back. And C.C. Stiper needs a change. But before we do that, Angela, I want to give you your gift. Oh, okay. All right. Here it is, I wrapped it.
好的。我们回来了。CC臭得需要换衣服。但在我们做那件事之前，安吉拉，我想把你的礼物给你。哦，好的。好吧。在这里，我把它包装好了。
You really did. So, you know, we shared with everyone last week that we got desks and that we opened the mail wait before you look. What? I want to give it. I thought I was asking a lot of it. Okay.
你真的这么做了。所以，你知道的，我们上周与大家分享了我们收到了桌子，我们在打开信件，等等，在你看着之前。什么？我想把它。我以为我要求很多。好的。
I just want to say, what have you been saying you wish you had? A letter opener. Cause there's so many letters. Yes. And I've been opening them with my little finger and I snagged that little side part of your fingernail. So here, this is my best shoulder letter opener for you. Oh, the nice watch.
我只想说，你一直在说你希望你有什么？一个拆信刀。因为有那么多信。是的。我一直用我的小手指拆信，我把你的指甲边缘给刮了一下。所以给你，这是我为你准备的最佳冰火拆信刀。哦，这表真好。
Wait, it's a game of thrones. Yeah, it's a game of thrones letter opener. Oh my gosh. It is the long claw sword letter opener. Yes. Yeah. Winter is coming and so is your mail. So here's the thing. I really wanted to get Arya's sword for you. By the way, I don't know anything about what I'm saying.
等等，这是一个权力的游戏。是的，这是一个权力的游戏拆信刀。哦，天哪。它是长爪剑拆信刀。是的。是的，冬天来了，你的信件也来了。所以事情是这样的。我真的很想为你弄到艾莉亚的剑。顺便说一句，我对我说的话一无所知。
I did a lot of googling to figure out like what game of thrones item. This is one of the most thoughtful gifts you've ever given me in all of our friendship. I mean, they don't from what I know make Arya sword into a letter opener. The needle, it's called the needle. The needle, yes, you can get a replica of it for your house, but you can't open letters with it. So I hope that this long-class sword is good. Yes, I love it. I will take a picture of it and I will open mail happily with it. Something that keeps coming up in our mail. I'm holding up my letter opener. Something that keeps coming up in our mail is what is next for office ladies.
我谷歌了很多来弄清楚权力的游戏有什么物品。这是我们所有友谊中你送给我的最体贴的礼物之一。我的意思是，据我所知，他们没有把艾莉亚的剑做成拆信刀。那根针，它叫缝衣针。缝衣针，是的，你可以为你的房子买一个复制品，但你不能用它拆信。所以我希望这把长爪剑很好。是的，我喜欢它。我会拍下它的照片，并且我会开心地用它拆信。有一件事一直在我们的信件中出现。我举起我的拆信刀。有一件事一直在我们的信件中出现，那就是办公室女郎的下一步是什么？
What are we doing next? Are we going to be ladies who Google? Are we gonna be mom detectives? What's our next podcast? Are we gonna do movies? I know, lady. This is the question because I can't believe what do we have like a year?
我们接下来要做什么？我们要成为会谷歌的女士吗？我们要成为妈妈侦探吗？我们的下一个播客是什么？我们要拍电影吗？我知道，美女。这是个问题，因为我不敢相信我们有大约一年时间？
Oh, MG. I know. I like it here. I want to keep doing this with you. I love our office ladies family. I know me too. So we do need to figure out what's next. I think we should, we should try some stuff out.
哦，天哪。我知道。我喜欢这里。我想继续和你一起做这件事。我爱我们的办公室女郎大家庭。我知道我也是。所以我们确实需要弄清楚下一步是什么。我想我们应该，我们应该尝试一些东西。
That's how we got here, right? We put the phone between us and we started chatting. What should we do next? Like a bonus episode, like on a Monday or something. Oh, this has gotten bigger. I thought we were going to be in your garage again, but yes, you were right. We could. What are we do next? Like a bonus episode, like on a Monday or something. Oh, this has gotten bigger. I thought we were gonna be in your garage again, but yes, you were right. What we could?
我们就是这样走到这一步的，对吧？我们把电话放在我们中间，然后开始聊天。我们接下来应该做些什么？就像一个加长版单集，在周一或别的什么时间。哦，这变得更大了。我以为我们会再次在你的车库里，但是的，你是对的。我们能。我们接下来要做什么？就像一个加长版单集，在周一或别的什么时间。哦，这变得更大了。我以为我们会再次在你的车库里，但是的你对了。我们能吗？
What are we gonna do? Just sit, record, not play for anyone? Okay, you're right. You're right, okay, yes, I like this bonus episode, but what should we talk about? I like the idea of doing maybe, let's break down a movie. Ooh, what movie?
我们要干什么？只是坐着，录音，不为任何人播放？好吧，你是对的。你是对的，好吧，是的，我喜欢这个加长版单集，但我们应该聊些什么？我喜欢这个主意，也许，让我们剖析一部电影。哦，什么电影？
Ooh, should we put it in office? Pod, people can weigh in. What movie, guys? What movie? Why, should we put it in Office Laze pod? People can weigh in. What movie, guys? What movie? Why are you even asking this question? It's so obvious that this movie is... Is John Wick? Yes, or stars, canaries. Oh, what about speed?
哦，我们应该把它发到《办公室》播客吗？大家可以权衡一下。什么电影，伙计们？什么电影？为什么你还要问这个问题？很明显这部电影是……是《疾速追杀》吗？是的，或者是《星际迷航》。哦，那《生死时速》呢？
Oh, I love speed. That's how I started on my piano journey. That was your introduction to piano? Yes, that was my gateway drug into Keanu. Pop quiz at the f***hole. Yeah. I'm ready. I'm ready. Oh, and we know Beth Grant. Oh, she would give us all the inside info
哦，我喜欢《生死时速》。那是我的钢琴之旅的开始。那是你对钢琴的引路人？是的，那是我通往基努的大门毒品。测验在山洞里。是的。我准备好了。我准备好了。哦，我们认识贝丝·格兰特。哦，她会给我们所有内幕消息
on sitting on that bus I'm sure. Beth Grant played Dwight's babysitter slash date to dinner party. Mm-hmm. She was also on the bus in speed. Oh, guys, it's coming together. I feel very inspired by this speed idea. Should we put it to a vote, though, because I would love to point out some background details in John Wick that I know you missed.
关于坐在那辆公共汽车上，我确信。贝丝·格兰特饰演德怀特的保姆兼“晚宴派对”的约会对象。嗯哼。她也在《生死时速》的公共汽车上。哦，伙计们，这组合在一起了。我觉得这个《生死时速》的想法非常鼓舞人心。不过我们应该把它付诸表决吗，因为我很想指出《疾速追杀》中一些我知道你错过的背景细节？
A.K.A. the coffee maker. A.K.A. Excuse me. Do not even come to me. You're going to want to back away from that statement about things I missed. And the first time you ever watched it, you stopped watching it 15 minutes. This is the other podcast idea we could do. Just the first 15 minutes of every movie, we call it Jenna's breakdown. Well, I would thrive on that podcast because I'm very good at watching the first 15 to 20 minutes
也就是咖啡机。也就是。对不起。甚至不要来找我。你会想要从关于我错过的事情的那个声明中退缩。而你第一次看的时候，你在15分钟时就停止观看了。这是我们可以做的另一个播客主意。每部电影的前15分钟，我们称之为詹妮弗的剖析。好吧，我会在那个播客中茁壮成长，因为我非常擅长观看一部电影的前15到20分钟
of a film. I know. And then you fall asleep. But I come back. You do. In the days that follow. OK, well, we should get back to this episode. That's lost to think about. And it all started with my letter opener. Thank you. What a gift.
。我知道。然后你就睡着了。但我会回来的。你确实会。在接下来的日子里。好吧，我们应该回到这一集。有太多要想的了。这一切都从我的拆信刀开始。谢谢。多棒的礼物啊。
What a gift. That letter opener may lead to our next thing. Who knew? Who knew? But that is the power of the long-class sword. Clearly. I don't know what I'm talking about, but is that true? Does it hold power? I hope I willed it with the justice it deserves.
多棒的礼物啊。那个拆信刀可能会引领我们的下一件事。谁知道呢？谁知道呢？但这就是长爪剑的力量。显然。我不知道我在说什么，但那是真的吗？它拥有力量吗？我希望我用它应得的正义来挥舞它。
Let's pivot back into this episode because CC has pooped all over her christening dress. And Jim is going to hustle out to his car. This was such a real dad moment for me. Like he's like looking desperately and ofM. has packed a backup outfit. Yeah, Jim said that he saw it in there. He checked. He didn't bring it. Yeah, he did say that is what he says.
让我们转回这一集，因为CC把粪便拉满了她的洗礼长袍。吉姆将急忙赶到他的车上。对我来说，这是一个非常真实的爸爸时刻。就像他绝望地看着，而且帕姆已经打包了一套备用衣服。是的，吉姆说他在里面看到了。他检查过了。他没带。是的，他确实这么说了，这就是他说的。
There's two lines that Jim has that made me laugh so hard as a parent. First of all, he says to P.M., this is happening. Yeah. Because you've had those moments where like one parent has already halfway down the road and they're bringing the other one up to speed and they're like, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the,
吉姆有两句台词让我这个父母笑得前俯后仰。首先，他对帕姆说，“这正在发生。”是的。因为你经历过这样的时刻，比如一个父母已经在路上走了一半，他们正在向另一个父母通报最新情况，他们就像是，这个，这个，这个，这个，
this is happening. Trust me. This is, yeah. This was our best option was this t-shirt. So we're gonna go from here. And then she's like, no, there's this backup outfit. You said you checked the bag and he's like, I did say that. That's what I said. Maybe not what I did. So I loved those. And I personally was charmed by the
这正在发生。相信我。这是，是的。我们最好的选择就是这件T恤。所以我们要从这里开始。然后她就像是，不，这里有一套备用衣服。你说你检查过包，而他就像是，我确实说过。这就是我说的。也许不是我做的。所以我很喜欢那些。我个人被
fact that all of their photos from the day would have C.C. in this t-shirt. That would just become fun family lore, in my opinion.. Like if that happened to my kids, they would be so delighted to look those pictures and hear that story again. It would be like, right? Like you can't get too upset over these moments. Well, the christening is over and Stanley thinks he can go,
这样一个事实迷住了，他们当天的所有照片都会让CC穿着这件T恤。在我看来，这只会成为有趣的家庭传说。就像如果那发生我的孩子身上，他们会非常高兴地看着那些照片并再次听到这个故事。这就好像，对吧？就像你不能对这些时刻太沮丧一样。好吧，洗礼结束了，斯坦利认为他可以走了，
but the pastor's gonna let everyone know that the halberts are hosting a reception next door. For everyone. Yep. Everyone's invited. Well, this mistake really angered Chelsea L from Houston, Texas. I want to say that in Chelsea's letter, there are a lot of all caps. Chelsea, what got you was at the Halbert.
但牧师要让每个人都知道哈珀特一家正在隔壁举办招待会。为了每个人。是的。每个人都被邀请了。好吧，这个错误真的激怒了来自德克萨斯州休斯顿的切尔西·L。我想说，在切尔西的信中，有很多全大写字母。切尔西，惹恼你的是在哈珀特那里。
It was so many things. Here is what Chelsea said. Quote, okay, this bothers me so much every time I see this episode. Why does Jim not correct the minister when she announces the Halbert reception? Come on, Jim. Or Pam, I suppose Pam could have corrected this too. And I don't think anyone in the church would be angry if they corrected the minister and asked folks not to come to the reception unless they knew Jim and Pam.
有太多事情了。切尔西是这样说的。引述如下，“好吧，每次我看到这一集，这都让我很烦恼。为什么当牧师宣布哈珀特招待会时，吉姆不纠正她？拜托，吉姆。或者帕姆，我想帕姆也可以纠正这一点。而且我不认为教堂里的任何人会因为他们纠正牧师并要求人们除非认识吉姆和帕姆否则不要去招待会而生气的。”
This makes me so irrationally angry for them. She'll see. But Jim and Pam do not correct the minister. Instead, they are now going to host a reception for which they do not have enough food. Well, this is kind of a recurring thing with Jim's last name because it happened in Niagara as well. Remember, outside of the reception, there was a sign that said they help print? Yes.
这让我为他们感到莫名其妙地愤怒。切尔西。但吉姆和帕姆没有纠正牧师。相反，他们现在要举办一场他们没有足够食物的招待会。好吧，这在吉姆的姓氏上是件经常发生的事情，因为在《尼亚加拉》中也发生过。还记得，在招待会外面，有一个牌子写着他们帮助打印吗？是的。
Reception? This happens to me all the time. People put an L in my last name so they'll say, Kinsley. I've heard people call you Kinsley over and over. It is time for the reception. It is very crowded. Angela is going to clock this right away. And I have one of my lines that is quoted to me coming up. I have seen it stitched on a pillow.
招待会？这种事我经常遇到。人们在我的姓氏里加了一个L，所以他们会说，金斯利。我听过人们一次又一次地叫你金斯利。是时候去招待会了。人非常多。安吉拉马上就会注意到这一点。我即将迎来一句被人引用给我的台词。我看到它被绣在枕头上。
Angela says to Pam, you don't know them all. Pam says nope, and we're going to need a loaves and fish is kind of miracle to feed them all. And that's when Angela says, Jesus is not your caterer. But he should be your caterer, because you're a little angel. Why didn't your parents get you a caterer? And now do you know what I improvised? Because they don't think. So Southern.
安吉拉对帕姆说，“你并不认识他们所有人。”帕姆说，“不，我们需要一场‘五饼二鱼’式的奇迹来养活他们所有人。”就在那时安吉拉说，“耶稣不是你的餐饮服务商。”但祂本该是你的餐饮服务商，因为你是个小天使。为什么你父母不给你找个餐饮服务商？现在你知道我即兴发挥了什么吗？因为他们不会想。太南方了。
When I heard it, I was like, they don't think. Everyone is hungry. Everyone is angry. There's a lot of angry folks at this reception. Well, Angela isn't the only person who's miffed at the lack of food. We also have to deal with Doug McPherson Davies' uncle. That's one of my favorite character names. He was played by Emil Beheshdie, who is a very accomplished comedic actor. He's been on Will and Grace, the King of Queens,
当我听到它的时候，我当时就想，他们不会想。每个人都很饿。每个人都很生气。在这个招待会有很多生气的人。好吧，安吉拉并不是唯一对缺乏食物感到恼火的人。我们还得对付道格·麦克弗森·戴维斯的叔叔。那是我最喜欢的角色名字之一。他由埃米尔·贝赫什蒂饰演，他是一位非常有成就的喜剧演员。他曾出演过《威尔和格蕾丝》、《皇后区之王》。
Greg the Bunny, grounded for life, big love. The list goes on and on. Even after finding out there's not really any food. Everyone is still staying. Leave everybody just go away. My favorite grump was Scone's E-Citer. Scone's E-Citer, Lady, there is a Twitter page for Scone's E-Citer. No way. Yes, it is basically a bunch of posts a Twitter page for Scone's E Cider. No way. Yes, it is basically a bunch of posts about Cider and Scone's.
《兔子格雷格》，终身禁足，大爱无疆。这样的例子还有很多。甚至在发现其实没什么食物之后，大家还是都留了下来。让所有人直接走开吧。我最喜欢的怪人是斯康斯·E·赛特。斯康斯·E·赛特，天哪，推特上甚至有一个关于斯康斯·E·赛特的账号。怎么可能。是的，它基本上就是一堆关于赛德和斯康斯的推文。
Also, if you'd like a Scone's E Cider bumper sticker, you can find one over on the Etsy page. That's what soap said. We even got a fan question from Patrick R in Ailsbury, UK, who said I did a mini deep dive on Scone's E citer and I find out that if someone questions where the food and drink is at at a party, you call them a Scone's E citer. It's a whole thing. That is awesome. We've got to start using Scone's E citer. Why haven't we been using that all this time? Well, because we haven't done this rewatch yet
另外，如果你想要一张斯康斯·E·赛特的汽车贴纸，你可以在Etsy主页上找到。肥皂就是这么说的。我们甚至收到了来自英国艾尔斯伯里帕特里克·R的粉丝提问，他说我对斯康斯·E·赛特进行了一次微深度挖掘，我发现如果有人在派对上质疑食物和饮料在哪里，你就称他们为斯康斯·E·赛特。这成了一个梗。太棒了。我们得开始使用斯康斯·E·赛特这个词了。为什么我们这么久以来一直没用过它？嗯，因为我们还没做过这次重看。
and now we have and now we have a new catchphrase. Don't be a scone scone scone scone scider. She's amazing. Well, scone scone scider was played by actress Stephanie McVeigh. She's been on Parks and Rec and Superstore and like a gazillion things because she's fantastic. I didn't point it out earlier, but she had a great background detail in the church.
现在我们看了，现在我们有了一个新的口头禅。别当个斯康斯·E·赛特。她太棒了。嗯，斯康斯·E·赛特这个角色由演员斯蒂芬妮·麦克维扮演。她演过《公园与游憩》、《超级商店》以及无数部作品，因为她太棒了。我刚才没指出来，但在教堂里她有一个很棒的背景细节。
It's at eight minutes and 25 seconds, scounsey cider is putting on powder with a little compact. So, you know, before she gets up to go to the reception to be disappointed by the lack of food she is going to powder her face. Carla is going to stand up and give a really great speech about the youth ministry, and she thinks Jim and Pam are hosting them, because after this reception, they're going to Mexico. They're gonna spend three months building a school. Yes, and Michael is really inspired by the joy
在8分25秒时，斯康斯·E·赛特正用一个小粉盒扑粉。所以，你知道的，在她起身去招待会，对食物的匮乏感到失望之前，她要扑扑粉。卡拉站起来发表了一场非常精彩的关于青年团契的演讲，她以为吉姆和帕姆在招待他们，因为在这个招待会之后，他们要前往墨西哥。他们要花三个月时间建一所学校。是的，迈克尔真的被青年团契桌子散发出的那种快乐所感染了
that's sort of emanating from this youth ministry table, and nobody else is taking it seriously. We got table of sass, basically. So much sass. And Michael is like, let's go build an airport. Okay, we'll start small with a car wash. Ryan is like spinning his iPad. What's up with Ryan and his iPad?
而其他人都没有认真对待。基本上就是刻薄桌。充满了刻薄。迈克尔就像是，我们去建个机场吧。好吧，我们从小事做起，开个洗车行。瑞恩一直在转他的iPad。瑞恩和他的iPad是怎么回事？
This is the second thing he's brought it to that it's not appropriate. He brought it to Andy's play. Oh yeah, you're right. And now here it is at the christening. Well, Michael is just like, guys, I don't get it. We should hang out more. Like I think he's seeing the fellowship of that table
这是他第二次把iPad带到不合时宜的场合了。他把它带到了安迪的戏剧演出现场。哦对，你说得对。现在它又出现在了洗礼仪式上。好吧，迈克尔只是觉得，伙计们，我不明白。我们应该多聚聚。就像我觉得他看到了那个桌子的情谊
and he's seeing the lack of fellowship at their table. And then Darrell has the best sass line. I loved it so much. He says, we are hanging out right now. You want some more of this? Yeah. It's so more of this? Yeah. It's so good. I loved it.
他看到了他们桌子缺乏情谊。然后达里尔说了一句最刻薄的话。我太喜欢了。他说，我们现在不就在聚吗？你还想来点这个吗？对。就是这样。太棒了。我太喜欢了。
Michael is so bummed out by his table that he's going to storm out at 12 minutes, 48 seconds. Did you see the sign? Is he leaves the reception hall? No. It says Halbert, Christening reception. They made a whole sign. Yeah.
迈克尔对他的桌子感到非常沮丧，以至于他在12分48秒时夺门而出。你看到那个标志了吗？当他离开招待大厅时。没有。上面写着，哈尔伯特，洗礼招待会。他们甚至特地做了个标志。是的。
Oh. Well, meanwhile, Pam is going to go out. She's going to grab some subs and sodas. Yeah, everyone's hungry. They need to get more food. Well, Jim is going to be looking for some chairs and he needs a place. That's quiet for Cece. Jim finds me on a little side room on a sofa, just sitting by herself.
哦。好吧，与此同时，帕姆要出去了。她要去拿一些三明治和苏打水。是的，每个人都饿了。他们需要弄点吃的。好吧，吉姆要去找几把椅子，他需要一个地方。对西西来说很安静。吉姆在沙发上的一个小侧室找到了我，我正独自坐着。
And this is what she has to say. Oh hey, Mima, would you watch CC for a second? Don't worry, she's asleep. I'm just going to track down some more chairs. Fine. Fine, I guess I'll watch Suzanne's pertain go, baby. Watch Suzanne's pertain go, and your baby. I want to say later when Jim comes back and he can't find Cece. He comes into Mima again and he's like Mima,
这是她要说的。哦，嘿，米玛，你能帮我照看一会儿西西吗？别担心，她睡着了。我去找几把椅子。好吧。好吧，我想我来看着苏珊的孙女，还有你的宝宝。我想说后来当吉姆回来却找不到西西时。他又去找米玛，他说米玛，
where is Cece? She says I lost the purse too. Yeah, yeah, she's so matter of fact, she's like, I don't know. It's so, she doesn't even turn around and look at them. Well, like you said, Jim is on the hunt for some chairs, but we had a fan catch from Kristen H and Austin, Texas, and Jesse T from Chicago, Illinois,
西西在哪里？她说我也把钱包弄丢了。对，对，她太淡定了，她就像是，我不知道。就是这样，她甚至都不转身看他们一眼。嗯，正如你所说，吉姆正在寻找椅子，但我们收到了来自德克萨斯州奥斯汀的克里斯汀·H和伊利诺伊州芝加哥的杰西·T的粉丝抓包，
who said, when Jim gives Ceci to Pam's Mima, he says he's looking for chairs. Why does he not just use the chairs right behind him in that room? Are those special, holy church chairs? Lady, it's true. There is a dining table surrounded by chairs and he walks right past them.
他们说，当吉姆把西西交给帕姆的米玛时，他说他在找椅子。他为什么不直接用那个房间里他身后的椅子呢？难道那些是神圣的教堂特许椅子吗？天哪，真的。那里有一张周围摆满椅子的餐桌，他直接从旁边走了过去。
It says I need to find some chairs. I didn't catch that, that's great. I mean, I thought maybe he's looking for some folding chairs or something, but there are clearly eight chairs right there. Didn't need to look so hard. Well it is time for the youth ministry to leave. Their bus is waiting and people are gathering outside kind of making a long line to give them high fives and hugs as they go. It kind of reminded me of like when a football team is entering the stadium and people give them the high five as they take the field. Yeah, and Michael joins right in. He's just very into it. He's wishing them all the best.
上面写着我需要找几把椅子。我没注意到，这太棒了。我的意思是，我以为他可能在找折叠椅什么的，但那里明明有八把椅子。没必要找得那么辛苦。好吧，青年团契该走了。他们的巴士在外面等着，人们聚集在外面排成长队，在他们离开时给他们击掌和拥抱。这有点让我想起橄榄球队进入体育场时，人们在他们上场时与他们击掌的情景。是的，迈克尔直接加入了。他非常投入。他祝他们一切顺利。
He's really caught up in this and all of a sudden he's like, you know what? I'm going with him. Yep, and he gets on the bus. We had a fan catch from Maricella K and Riverside, California, who said, We had a fan catch from Mara Sella Kay and Riverside, California, who said, at 13 minutes and 45 seconds, did anyone else notice that the camera crew was already on the bus? And like in the back of the bus before Michael even got on? How did they notice that? I totally noticed that. And I was like, why is the camera crew on the bus?
他真的完全投入进去了，突然他说，你知道吗？我和他们一起去。没错，他上了车。我们收到了加利福尼亚州河滨市的玛丽塞拉·K的粉丝抓包，他说，我们收到了加利福尼亚州河滨市的玛丽塞拉·K的粉丝抓包，她说，在13分45秒时，有人注意到摄像团队已经在车上了吗？而且在迈克尔上车之前就在巴士后面了？他们是怎么注意到的？我完全注意到了。当时我就想，为什么摄像团队会在车上？
We had another question from Liam M. and Brisbane, Australia, who said, was there ever a discussion in the writer's room about the integrity of the camera crew on the bus. We had another question from Liam M. and Brisbane, Australia, who said, was there ever a discussion in the writers room about the integrity of the camera crew? Would they have really gone all the way to Mexico? Yeah, I thought the same thing. Oh my goodness. None of them have any bags, including Michael. And then our other volunteer Andy.
我们收到了来自澳大利亚布里斯班的利亚姆·M的另一个问题，他说，编剧室里有没有讨论过车上摄像团队的真实性。我们收到了来自澳大利亚布里斯班的利亚姆·M的另一个问题，他说，编剧室里有没有讨论过摄像团队的真实性？他们真的会一路去墨西哥吗？是的，我也是这么想的。哦天哪。他们谁都没带包，包括迈克尔。然后是我们另一个志愿者安迪。
Well, Michael has a speech that he gives that cracked me up. Jenna, Phyllis says, Michael, what am I supposed to tell my clients if they ask about you? And Michael leaning out of the window of the bus says, tell them that I died. And I turned into an angel. And when they fill a breeze in a room with all the windows closed, or that chill on the back of their neck, that is just me watching over them. And then Phyllis is like, okay,
好吧，迈克尔发表了一段让我笑喷了的演讲。珍娜，菲利斯说，迈克尔，如果我的客户问起你，我该怎么告诉他们？迈克尔探出巴士车窗说，告诉他们我死了。我变成了一位天使。当他们在窗户全关的房间里感觉到微风，或者脖子后面感到发凉时，那其实就是我在守护他们。然后菲利斯说，好吧，
but what about the bigger corporate accounts? And Michael says, tell them I'm in a meeting. I loved all that too. And I love how Andy decides he's going as well. There's a great thing in deleted scenes. So you know they give Michael a t-shirt. Michael's very excited. Oh, he puts it on.
那更大的公司账户呢？迈克尔说，告诉他们我在开会。我也很喜欢所有这些。我喜欢安迪是如何决定他也要去的。删减片段里有一个很棒的桥段。你知道他们送了迈克尔一件T恤。迈克尔非常兴奋。哦，他把它穿上了。
Yeah. But under his suit jacket. Yeah. Over his shirt. Yes. Andy, when he gets on the bus, is like, can I get a shirt? They're like, we're all out.
对。但是穿在他的西装外套里面。是的。穿在他的衬衫外面。是的。安迪上车后说，我也能有一件衬衫吗？他们说，我们发完了。
Here you can have a pin. And if you guys go to 15 minutes and 41 seconds, you can see the pin on Andy's like jacket. All of this talk about being on a bus and travel is making me think of my journal. Oh, is it time? It is time because I used to write a lot in my journal when I was traveling.
给你，你可以拿个别针。如果你去到15分41秒，你能看到安迪夹克上的别针。所有这些关于坐巴士和旅行的谈话让我想起了我的日记。哦，是时候了吗？是时候了，因为我过去旅行时经常在日记里写很多东西。
Nothing like writing when you're on a bus or a plane. All right, Sam. Sam and I have both sat forward in our chairs with anticipation. Physically giddy. All right, you guys have a choice. Do you wanna hear what I've titled anniversary or do you wanna hear what I've titled, airplane do you want to hear what I've titled airplane?
没有什么比在巴士或飞机上写作更好的了。好了，萨姆。我和萨姆都满怀期待地将身体前倾坐在椅子上。兴奋得手舞足蹈。好吧，你们有一个选择。你们想听我把这篇命名为周年纪念，还是想听我命名为飞机，你们想听我命名为飞机吗？
Both please. Both. I must be selfish. Okay. Let's start with anniversary. September 10th, 1996. Oh my gosh. I don't like this. This is it.
两个都要，求你了。两个都要。我可不能太自私。好吧。我们从周年纪念开始。1996年9月10日。哦天哪。我不喜欢这个。就是这个。
Yeah. 128 PM. PM is underlined. Oh, just so you know. Today marks my one-year anniversary in Los Angeles, California. Oh! exclamation point. Hey!
对。下午1点28分。下午用下划线标出来了。哦，顺便让你们知道一下。今天标志着我在加利福尼亚州洛杉矶的一周年纪念日。哦！感叹号。嘿！
Can you believe it? Question exclamation point. Time has flown here. It crawled in New York. I haven't accomplished a great deal yet. Or have I accomplished a lot? Why is it in a riddle? The next part is so embarrassing. What is it? What is it? Oh gosh.
你们敢相信吗？问号加感叹号。这里的时光飞逝。在纽约它可是慢如蜗牛。我还没取得多大成就。或者我已经取得了很大成就？为什么它是个谜语？接下来这部分太尴尬了。是什么？是什么？哦天哪。
Angela's wiping tears for her eyes. Because it's so dorky, I was such a dork. I'm still a dork. OK. I haven't accomplished a great deal yet. Or I have accomplished a lot on whose measure am I judged? It's written in Game of Thrones. Oh my goodness. Oh my goodness.
安吉拉擦着眼里的泪水。因为太书呆子气了，我以前就是个书呆子。我现在还是个书呆子。好吧。我还没取得多大成就。或者我已经取得了很大成就，我是以谁的标准来评判的？这简直是用《权力的游戏》写出来的。哦天哪。哦天哪。
All right, that's how that one ends. Okay. Okay. Next one. Let's see the date here. December 24, 1996. Christmas Eve, Delta Airlines. Oh, okay. Okay. 5.16 PM Utah Airport. I just got bumped
好了，那篇就这样结束了。好吧。好吧。下一篇。让我们看看这里的日期。1996年12月24日。平安夜，达美航空。哦，好吧。好吧。下午5点16分，犹他机场。我刚刚被升到了
up to first class exclamation point. What a nice Christmas present exclamation point. Fun exclamation point. This has never happened to me. I am so psyched. A window seat in first class makes up for that two and a half hour layover in Salt Lake City. I'm drinking my complimentary pre-flight drink. Oh, and in first class, you get a hot meal. Ha! It caught on me, it gets a sack of lunch. Oh my gosh, now you get nothing. I know. I wonder if they upgraded me because I don't feel well.
头等舱！感叹号。多好的圣诞礼物啊！感叹号。太有趣了！感叹号。这事儿以前从来没发生在我身上。我太兴奋了。头等舱靠窗的座位总算弥补了我在盐湖城两个半小时的转机时间。我正在喝我的免费登机前饮料。哦，在头等舱，你还能吃上一顿热乎饭。哈！说起我，我只得到了一袋午餐。哦天哪，现在你什么都没有了。我知道。我在想他们是不是因为我感觉不舒服才给我升舱的。
My cold is getting worse. Ha! How would they know? Did you tell someone? I feel pretty sick. My nose is driving me crazy and dripping a lot. Did you go to the airport and go up so sorry about you? I don't feel the well.
我的感冒越来越严重了。哈！他们怎么会知道？你告诉别人了吗？我感觉很不舒服。我的鼻子快把我折腾疯了，一直在流鼻涕。你是不是去机场然后对别人说我很抱歉？我感觉很不舒服。
Well, first class rocks, but I feel really sick. I might be getting the flu. You know what? I want to see the journal entry of the person who's got next to you on this flight. My first time paying for first class and they seat me next to some sniffly running nose. Why died weirdo?
好吧，头等舱太棒了，但我真的感觉很不舒服。我可能得流感了。你知道吗？我想看看这趟航班坐在你旁边那人的日记。我第一次花钱坐头等舱，结果他们把我安排在一个一直吸鼻子流鼻涕的怪胎旁边。为什么他要死？
Who's downing a drink? Pre-flight. She keeps telling the flight attendants are sick. Okay. All right. The sturdis is the nicest lady. She's really taking good care of me. I'm pretty sure now I have a fever.
谁在一边狂喝饮料？登机前。她一直告诉乘务员她生病了。好吧。好吧。空姐是个极好的人。她把我照顾得很好。我现在基本确定我发烧了。
I'm getting worse. This is now two hours into the flight. Oh goodness. This is how it ends. Filling so sickly, exclamation point, sad face. Oh yeah. There you go. Did you have the flu?
我越来越难受了。飞行已经进行了两个小时。哦天哪。这就是结局。感觉好恶心，感叹号，悲伤的脸。哦，是的。给你。你得流感了吗？
Yeah, I caught the flu. I showed up on Christmas Eve with the flu. I like that it has callbacks like we've been, like not like the other airport, as if we're gonna be like, ah, I remember that entry. Well, wait, I didn't count on this one, but here is January 2nd, 1997.
对，我得了流感。我在平安夜带着流感出现。我喜欢它有像我们以前那样的回扣，就像不像另一个机场，好像我们要说，啊，我记得那个条目。好吧，等等，我没指望这个，但这里是1997年1月2日。
Well, 1997 is here. Can you believe it? You and the reader have been through so much. Oh gosh, all right, I'm gonna stop for today. My journals are so embarrassing. Thank you so much for that. Well, that was delightful, Angela. And I just wanna say we do also have the option
好吧，1997年到了。敢相信吗？你和读者经历了这么多。哦天哪，好吧，我今天要停下来了。我的日记太尴尬了。非常感谢你。嗯，那太棒了，安吉拉。我只想说我们确实还有这个选项
of a spin-off podcast called Angela's. No, no, we can't take it. I just say, no, as we figure out what's next. You can break down a journal entry each episode. Oh. Dives on it. I mean, who am I writing to? Always is the question.
一个名为安吉拉的衍生播客。不，不，我们不能接受。我只想说，不，当我们弄清楚下一步该做什么时。你可以在每一集里分解一个日记条目。哦。深入探讨。我的意思是，我在写给谁？一直都是个问题。
Okay. I'm sorry you were sick that Christmas. I know, that really stinks. But I did get to fly first class. You did? Yeah. The bus is on the road, and Toby has made it inside the church. Finally, and we had a fan catch from Sean L. in Indiana. It's wonderful. Sean said, this is not a question, but something fun to look out for. When Toby enters the church toward the end of the episode, you can see Dwight put his business cards inside of the Bibles in the pews.
好的。我很抱歉你那年圣诞节生病了。我知道，那真的很糟糕。但我确实坐了头等舱。真的吗？对。大巴在路上，托比已经进入了教堂。终于，我们收到了印第安纳州肖恩·L的粉丝留言。太棒了。肖恩说，这不是一个问题，而是一个值得注意的趣事。当托比在剧集接近尾声时进入教堂时，你可以看到德怀特把他的名片放进了长椅上的圣经里。
Oh, Sean, this is something I was about to bring up. Yes, it's at 15 minutes and 50 seconds, you can see Dwight's little business card popping out of the Bible. That's right. In deleted scenes, there is a scene. If you go to the DVD, Dwight is stuffing all of the Bibles and hymnals in all the pews with his business card. Incredible.
哦，肖恩，这是我正要提起的事。是的，在15分50秒时，你可以看到德怀特的小名片从圣经里探出来。没错。在删减片段中，有一个场景。如果你去看DVD，德怀特正在用他的名片塞满所有长椅上的圣经和赞美诗。太不可思议了。
Well, Jim is panicking. He cannot find CC. And someone says a little blonde lady took CC. Yes, that little blonde lady is Pam's mother, but Jim doesn't know that. So Justice Pam is entering with a tray of sub sandwiches. Jim screams, stop that woman, stop her now, she stole my baby.
好吧，吉姆慌了。他找不到CC了。有人说一个金发小女士带走了CC。是的，那个金发小女士是帕姆的妈妈，但吉姆不知道这一点。正当帕姆端着一托盘潜艇堡进来时，吉姆大喊，阻止那个女人，现在就阻止她，她偷了我的孩子。
Kevin grabs Angela and her big bag, right as Pam is entering, and they all collide and this tray of sub sandwiches goes flying in the air. Jenna, this was like a stunt for us. Do you remember? I do remember. They had to break it down. We had to time it out. Someone was queuing you on the outside. Brian had to be in the right place and I did and you had to come in. I'm not gonna lie. When I watched it, I thought my like tray fumble was a little forced. I don't know if you saw it. Like brought the two trays together, almost like symbols. It looked like a cartoon. It looked like loony tunes.
就在帕姆进来的时候，凯文抓住了安吉拉和她的一个大包，他们撞在了一起，这一托盘潜艇堡飞到了空中。珍娜，这对我们来说就像是一个特技。你还记得吗？我确实记得。他们不得不把它拆解。我们必须掌握时间。有人在外面给你cue。布赖恩必须在正确的位置，我必须去，而你必须进来。我不撒谎。当我观看它时，我认为我的托盘失误有点生硬。我不知道你有没有看到。就像把两个托盘合在一起，几乎像钹一样。它看起来像个卡通。看起来像乐一通。
It looked like so crazy. And I also wanted to know why silver platter? I don't know. She would be bringing them in and bags. This whole silver platter thing was so over the top. Well, we got a fan question from Kirsten W. and Fort Myers-Florida, who said, when Pam comes back from getting the subs,
看起来太疯狂了。而且我还想知道为什么是银盘？不知道。她会用袋子把它们带进来。这个银盘的事情太夸张了。好吧，我们收到了来自佛罗里达州麦尔兹堡的基尔斯滕·W的粉丝提问，她说，当帕姆拿完潜艇堡回来时，
she drops them when Angela bumps into her. And then they insinuate that they can't eat the subs because they fell on the ground, but all the subs were wrapped. So why couldn't they just pick them up and eat them? I agree. Yeah, I thought the same thing at first, but then I remembered that we were implying in our blocking that we were like stomping on them, that like when they were on the ground. They got tripped on and stepped on. Yeah.
她在安吉拉撞到她时把它们掉落了。然后他们暗示他们不能吃这些潜艇堡，因为它们掉在地上，但所有的潜艇堡都是包好的。那他们为什么不直接捡起来吃呢？我同意。是的，我一开始也这么想，但后来我记起我们在走位时暗示过我们在踩踏它们，当它们在地上时。它们被绊倒并被踩踏了。是的。
Because of the whole struggle with Kevin and Angela and the person, the stones. Yeah, that that was the idea, but like I said, I'm not sure we sold the moment. Exactly. Well, as we could have. I want to tell you who is selling the moment. There is a background actor behind Angela and Kevin while they're struggling with Angela's purse and the scones and all of that.
因为和凯文、安吉拉以及那个人的整个纠缠，那些司康饼。是的，那是主意，但就像我说的，我不确定我们是否把这个时刻表现到位了。确实。好吧，正如我们本可以做到的那样。我想告诉你谁把这个时刻表现到位了。在安吉拉和凯文与安吉拉的钱包、司康饼以及所有这些东西搏斗时，安吉拉和凯文身后有一个背景演员。
He gave me life. He is so horrified by this behavior. Oh my goodness. I wish I could see this. It's so good. And I was like so tickled by it. Well, Kevin's going to go through Angela's bag, thinking he's going to find a baby, but what he does find is thousands of scones, an Angela's bag, thousands, thousands. Thousands, thousands. Basically, sconesy cider is Angela's happy. Angela's the new sconesy cider. We got mail about this scone theft. Oh, yeah. Sarah M. from Harrisburg, Pennsylvania said, I never understood why Angela took all the scones. Did she do it to sabotage the christening luncheon? And then Susanna H from Clermont, Florida said, hot take, I think Angela stole the scones
他给了我生命。他对这种行为感到无比惊恐。哦天哪。我真希望我能看到这个。太棒了。我对此感到非常开心。好吧，凯文要搜查安吉拉的包，以为他会找到一个婴儿，但他找到的是数千个司康饼，在安吉拉的包里，数千个，数千个。数千个，数千个。基本上，司康饼西打就是安吉拉的快乐。安吉拉是新的司康饼西打。我们收到了关于这起司康饼盗窃案的邮件。哦，是的。来自宾夕法尼亚州哈里斯堡的萨拉·M说，我从来不明白为什么安吉拉拿走了所有的司康饼。她是为了破坏洗礼午宴吗？然后来自佛罗里达州克莱蒙特的苏珊娜·H说，一个热门观点，我认为安吉拉偷了司康饼
to make Pam and Jim look even worse for having so little food. I don't think she even likes scones. Oh Angela, what's your take? Strong words. Mm-hmm. Well, are you a saboteur? I don't think she's a saboteur. I think she might just be that person that takes extra roles when they leave a party or a few extra party favors or if you have fruit set out, she might take some of your bananas and apples. I think she might be that person. Well, before we're done closing out this reception,
让帕姆和吉姆因为食物太少而看起来更糟糕。我觉得她甚至都不喜欢司康饼。哦，安吉拉，你有什么看法？措辞强烈。嗯哼。好吧，你是个破坏者吗？我不认为她是个破坏者。我觉得她可能只是那种在离开派对时拿走额外点心或者拿几个额外的派对伴手礼的人，或者如果你摆出了水果，她可能会拿走你的一些香蕉和苹果。我想她可能是那种人。好吧，在我们结束这个招待会之前，
there was a deleted scene I'd like to talk about that happened at the reception. It was sort of the end of the day and a lot of people had left. And Jim and Pam finally got the small intimate gathering they were hoping for. And Jim gives a really sweet speech. I thought we should hear it.
有一个我想谈谈的删减片段，发生在招待会上。这有点像一天的结束，很多人已经离开了。而吉姆和帕姆终于得到了他们一直希望的小型温馨聚会。吉姆发表了一段非常甜蜜的演讲。我觉得我们应该听听。
We're gonna have your attention. Today we christened our daughter Cecilia Marie and yeah for a moment there I thought she was bailing on her own reception but I guess she decided to stick it out. We named CC after Pam's grandmother Cecilia and after my grandmother Marie and I always remember how cool Marie was. She loved people and she loved a full and crazy house.
请大家注意。今天我们为女儿塞西莉亚·玛丽举行了洗礼，是的，有一会儿我以为她要逃掉自己的招待会，但我想她决定坚持到底。我们以帕姆的祖母塞西莉亚和我的祖母玛丽的名字给CC命名，我总是记得玛丽有多酷。她热爱人们，她热爱一个满是人且热闹的房子。
And nothing ever rattled her. So she would have loved it here today. And we just hope that CC has that same care for you spirit. So thank you guys all for coming and sharing this special day with us. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
没有什么能让她慌乱。所以她会喜欢今天这里的。我们只希望CC也有那种关爱他人的精神。所以谢谢你们大家的到来，并与我们分享这个特殊的日子。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。
Thank you. Thank you. Who wants to go pick up Michael and Andy? Okay. So, that's how that really sweet speech ends. And when Pam says who wants to go pick up Michael and Andy, Aaron flies out of her seat. Doesn't say anything to Gabe or anyone and sprints out the door.
谢谢。谢谢。谁想去接迈克尔和安迪？好的。所以，这段非常甜蜜的演讲就是这样结束的。当帕姆说谁想去接迈克尔和安迪时，艾琳从座位上飞奔而出。对盖布或任何人什么都没说，冲出了大门。
Wow. Yeah. But wasn't that a sweet speech? That was really sweet. And we found out sort of inspiration for the baby's name. I love that. Well, I guess we should go to the bus because Michael and Andy are regretting their decision.
哇。是的。但那不是个很温馨的演讲吗？真的很温馨。我们算是知道了这个婴儿名字的灵感来源。我太喜欢了。好吧，我想我们该去大巴那儿了，因为迈克尔和安迪正在后悔他们的决定。
It's gonna take two days to get there. Their next stop is Tennessee. Yeah, Michael and Andy went off the bus. They're changing their minds. Full stop. And they asked the bus driver to stop the bus. The bus driver was played by Terry James. You know, Randy said that Alison Jones read stunt drivers for this role. They had to hold a certain category
到那里需要两天时间。他们的下一站是田纳西州。是的，迈克尔和安迪下了大巴。他们改变主意了。彻底停下。他们让大巴司机停车。大巴司机由特里·詹姆斯饰演。你知道，兰迪说艾莉森·琼斯为这个角色物色了特技司机。他们必须持有某种类别的
license because he was really hoping that the person they cast as this actor could actually drive the bus. So our stunt coordinator, Wally Crowder, suggested Terry James, he read for the role. He did great. And he could really drive during this scene. I thought Terry did so great. I loved it when he said you shouldn't talk to a bus driver. Yes. Well, they start making a scene. They're screaming, stop the bus, stop the bus.
驾照，因为他真的希望他们选中的这个演员能真正驾驶这辆大巴。所以我们的特技统筹沃利·克劳德建议了特里·詹姆斯，他为这个角色试镜了。他表现得很棒。在这场戏中他真的能开车。我觉得特里表现得太棒了。我特别喜欢他说你不应该跟大巴司机说话。是的。好吧，他们开始大闹。他们尖叫着，停车，停车。
Andy is, I mean, he's like starting to cry. And the young kids that are on the bus are like, what's going on? You guys was happening. Yeah, the female student was played by Eric Hummer. And then the other gentleman, the kind of scraggly-haired fella, we got some mail about him. And that led me down a road. Zianne from Amarillo, Texas said, my brother-in-law had a small guest spot in this episode. His name is Seth Ellison. He is the youth group kid with the scraggly hair that says, Are you coming with us and stop the dang bus? He is still in Hollywood working in comedy.
安吉拉是，我的意思是，他开始哭了。大巴上的小孩子们就像，怎么回事？你们在干嘛。是的，女学生由埃里克·哈默饰演。然后另一位先生，那种头发蓬乱的家伙，我们收到了一些关于他的邮件。这让我踏上了一段旅程。来自德克萨斯州阿马里洛的齐安说，我的小舅子在这集里有一个小客串角色。他的名叫塞思·埃利森。他就是那个头发蓬乱的青年团小伙子，他说，你们要跟我们一起去吗，把该死的大巴停下。他现在仍然在好莱坞从事喜剧工作。
In fact, he was on an episode of the gong show that Ed Helms judged. He has also been on America's Got Talent several times and traveled to other countries to be on their versions of the show. His stage name is Seth word. Angela Seth word. Yeah. Has appeared on 12 episodes of America's Got Talent over multiple seasons. Wow. Five episodes of the Gong show. He always appears as an type of animal. Who?
事实上，他曾出现在埃德·赫尔姆斯担任评委的一期《贡秀》节目中。他还多次登上《美国达人秀》，并前往其他国家参加他们那里的节目版本。他的艺名是塞思·沃德。安吉拉，塞思·沃德。是的。在多个季节中曾出现在12集的《美国达人秀》中。哇。5集的《贡秀》。他总是以某种动物的形象出现。谁？
I don't how to explain it. But he has been Seth word the worm, Seth word the phoenix, Seth word the peacock, Seth word the walrus, the caterpillar, the snake, the chicken, the cow, and the bunny. What does he do when he's in the animal? Well, it's very interesting. So the first one that I saw was Suthward, the caterpillar. Okay. He is in a caterpillar outfit. And when he comes out onto the stage, he falls down.
我不知道该怎么解释。但他曾是塞思·沃德虫子，塞思·沃德凤凰，塞思·沃德孔雀，塞思·沃德海象，毛毛虫，蛇，鸡，牛和兔子。当他变成动物时他做什么？嗯，非常有趣。所以我看到的第一个是塞思·沃德毛毛虫。好的。他穿着一套毛毛虫服装。当他走到舞台上时，他摔倒了。
He rolls off the stage and then he goes up on the stage and he goes through a metamorphosis and turns into a butterfly, but they didn't let him finish. They judged him out. But he became sort of like an audience favorite. So he came back multiple times. Finally, they let him move forward. But he was just a recurring, like a recurring fan favorite of the show of America's Got Talent coming back in different forms every time. I went
他从舞台上滚下去，然后他走到舞台上，经历了一次蜕变，变成了一蝴蝶，但他们没让他完成。他们按铃淘汰了他。但他不知怎么成了观众最喜爱的人。所以他多次回归。最后，他们让他晋级了。但他只是一个反复出现的，类似于《美国达人秀》中反复出现的粉丝最爱，每次以不同的形态回归。我陷入了
down a rabbit hole. I watched all of his appearances. Is it lots of like physical comedy? Yes. Yes. But also just very charming and funny. I'll have to check it out, Seth Word. Well, they finally stopped the bus and let them off and We see that they call someone to come get them and it is Aaron. Yes, and another student gets off the bus with them too That's that's right. He's like don't tell my parents That student was played by Jeff Loveness. He's a writer performer He's worked on Rick and Morty the onion news, and has been a writer for the Emmys and Oscar-televised programs. We got some fan mail from Alania D in Wisconsin and Lauren H. and Santa Clarita, California, who both pointed out that he looks a lot like Steve
一个深洞。我看了他所有的出场。这其中有很多肢体喜剧吗？是的。是的。但也非常迷人且有趣。我得去看看，塞思·沃德。好吧，他们终于停下大巴让他们下车，我们看到他们打电话叫人来接他们，来的是艾琳。是的，另一个学生也和他们一起下了车。没错。他就像，别告诉我的父母。那个学生由杰夫·洛文尼斯饰演。他是一个编剧兼演员，他曾在《瑞克和莫蒂》、《洋葱新闻》工作，并担任过艾美奖和奥斯卡电视节目的编剧。我们收到了来自威斯康星州的阿兰妮·D和加利福尼亚州圣克拉丽塔的劳伦·H的粉丝来信，他们都指出他看起来非常像史蒂夫
Correll. They thought he looked like Steve's teenage doppelganger. They wanted to know if he was related to Steve, but he's not. No, he's not. I can't kind of see it. Well, they're gonna get in with Aaron and Michael wants to know is the reception still going on and she said, no, most everyone left. In fact, I think they all went to see a movie.
卡瑞尔。他们以为他看起来像史蒂夫的少年替身。他们想知道他是否与史蒂夫有亲戚关系，但并没有。不，他没有。我确实能看出一点。好吧，他们要上艾琳的车了，迈克尔想知道招待会还在进行吗，她说，没有，几乎所有人都走了。事实上，我想他们都去看电影了。
And Michael got what he wanted. Everyone's hanging out. They're having a memory together. And he's very happy to be back in this country. Yes, the country he never left. That's right. Well, that was christening everybody. Thank you so much to Randy Cordray for sharing
而迈克尔得到了他想要的。每个人都在一起闲逛。他们一起创造了回忆。他非常高兴能回到这个国家。是的，他从未离开过的国家。没错。好吧，这就是洗礼，各位。非常感谢兰迪·科德雷与我们分享
behind the scenes details with us. And thank you James Carey for sending me over those call sheets. Sam and Cassie, you guys are the best. Thanks for sitting through my journal entry. And Jenna, I can't wait to open letters with my letter opener. I can't wait to watch you do it. It will bring me joy. Have a great week, you guys.
幕后细节。也谢谢詹姆斯·凯瑞把那些通告单发给我。萨姆和卡西，你们是最棒的。谢谢你们听我读日记条目。还有珍娜，我迫不及待地想用我的信封刀拆信了。我迫不及待地想看你这么做。这会给我带来快乐。祝你们这周过得愉快，各位。
We'll see you next time. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO Jennifer Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Keifer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is rubber tree by Creed Ratten. For add-free versions of office ladies, go to stitur premium dot com. For a free one month trial at stitur premium,
我们下次见。詹妮弗·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·凯弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里·拉滕的《橡树》。如需无广告版本的办公室女士，请访问 stitur premium dot com。在 Stitur Premium 免费试用一个月，
use code office. trial at Stitcher Premium Use Code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
使用代码 office. trial 在 Stitcher Premium 使用代码 Office。本集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。